il se définit lui-même comme un
humaniste attristé l'académicien
Théodore mono qui fête aujourd'hui ses
95 ans et qui a consacré sa vie au
Sahara reste l'une des dernières
consciences de notre époque Daniel
vololfrom et Jean-François chevet l'ont
rencontré au Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle
un explorateur avec un Grand T un
personnage avec un grand P
8h37p voilà maintenant on va marcher une
fois encore muni de son carnet de bord
Théodore mono repartait dans le désert
il avait alors 86
ans but de l'expédition retrouver les
traces d'une météorite géante qu'il
avait découverte dans les années
30 70 années d'exploration saharienne
des dizaines de milliers d'objets mis à
jour Théodore mono rend aujourd'hui
hommage à son animal
fétiche n'aurit jamais pu circuler au S
sans le sans le drmadaire et et sans les
chef puisque les PO de Bou les autres
sont en peau de
chèvre c'est pour ça que vous portez la
boutonnière c'est pour ça que mon
premier livre qui
s'appelait37 éta était dédié au chameau
et au
bou au véhicule et au récipient au deux
seuls vainqueurs du Sara et vous êtes
toujours à votre poste là ce siège je de
fois par jour monsur bien
sûr à faire seulement aveugle maintenant
je peux plus ni lire ni écrire ce qui
n'est pas très pratique vous travaillez
encore sur quelque chose de PE ah oui
dans différents domaines je termine
actuellement un travail que j'ai entamé
il y a une 6aine d'années à Dakar sur
l'anatomie de la tête des de ce qu'on
appelle les poissons perroquet ils ont
une sorte de Meul faringienne qui leur
permet de de réduire en poudre les
petits fr
de de calcaire qu'ils ingervent l'étude
de la faune marine voilà bien le
paradoxe pour cet amoureux du désert
mais c'est par l'observation des
poissons qu'il a commencé au Muséum en
1922 avant d'être hé par le Sahara
Occidental qu'il a parcouru en tout sens
curieux de tout à la manière d'un
encyclopédiste du 18e siècle et là ces
cahers c'est les cahers les cahers jour
chaque jour il y avait la page de droite
ce qu'on avait fait dans la journée dans
la page de gauche la ce qu'on avait vu
les la liste des des chantillons
récoltés des numéros dans la marche
c'est ça actuellement j'en suis à
200400 mais à la seule évocation de
l'avenir ce pacifiste devient sombre et
amè donc vivre dans une société qui
repose directement sur le profit et sur
l'argent tant qu'elle sera profitable de
saccager la
nature on continuera à saccager la
nature sans le moindre
bien entendu pour Théodore mono
l'humaniste l'amoureux de la vie s' est
une espèce qui a peu d'avenir sur Terre
à cause de ses folie et de sa cruauté
c'est bien l'espèce
humaine